et en direct avec nous également le
journaliste franco américain gerald
olivier chercheurs ali ps l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe et
auteur du livre sur la route de la
maison blanche aux éditions jean
picollec
mais gérald olivier bonjour merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur arte france
pour cet après midi si particulière on
l'a vu tout à l'heure
quatre secondes de poignée de main entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden léger
sourire de chaque côté un petit salut à
la presse de la part du président russe
ce sont des sourires de façade
comment est ce que vous vous analysé ce
protocole oblige et côté je note que
vous avez minutes et la poignée de main
c'est très journalistique aujourd'hui
j'avais pas minutes et la poignée de
main je remarque une chose on a un
président américain joe biden qui malgré
tout porte sondages on voit un tout
petit peu courbé il voit là il a un
petit peu raide sur ses jambes
on a un président russe qui est très sûr
de sa personne mais en fait on a un
protocole qui est assez habituel et qui
va être très policé logique
maintenant ce qui est intéressant c'est
ce qui va se dire derrière et moi ce que
j'ai envie de remarquer c'est que ce
procès ce procès ce sommet est paradoxal
parce que on est à un moment où les
relations entre la russie et les etats
unis sont difficiles je rappelle que
vous avez des sanctions économiques y
sont en place depuis un certain temps
contre la russie je rappelle que du fait
d'un certain nombre d'incidents récents
les deux pays ont rappelé leurs
ambassadeurs etc actuellement il n'y a
pas d'ambassadeur américain à moscou ni
l'ambassadeur russe en washington il ya
des gens en poste mais ils ne sont pas à
leur poste ils ont été rappelés par lens
entre chancellerie donc on est dans un
moment de tension mais en même temps on
est très très loin des sommets de la
guerre froide où l' équilibre du monde
dépend des de l'issue de ce sommet est
géré même dire que actuellement s'il ya
bien un point où ces deux nations sont
en d'accord c'est sur celui de la
nécessité du désarmement et comme le
rappelait votre reportage il ya une
minute
ils ont tous les deux renouvelé leurs
accords d'un
d'un accord de désarmement qui s'appelle
start et il sera peut-être question de
renouveler ou de relancer d'autres
accords dont les deux pays sont sortis
récemment notamment sur les missiles à
portée intermédiaire en tous les cas on
est plus dans un moment de guerre froide
où l'issue du sommet pouvait être une
guerre thermonucléaire et même si les
relations entre les deux pays ne sont
pas au mieux de ce qu'elles ont été la
tension n'est pas aussi forte qu'elle a
pu être par le passé on aura peut être
toujours présent avec nous vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure gérald la
question de la stabilité stratégique et
à l'agenda cet après-midi envers le voir
donc avec deux traité ciel ouvert et new
start iii l'un clôt définitivement
l'autre prolongé à quoi s'attendre sur
ce sujet ran cet après midi en fait
c'est la question au fond si je peux me
permettre est votre premier reportage
sur le ciel ouvert était très
intéressant par qui soulignait cette
idée de confiance et j'estime
personnellement que on en est toujours
dans un moment où l'on essaie de gérer
l'après guerre froide
c'est à dire que suite à l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique
on a eu dans les années 90 une période
très ouverte où la nouvelle russie a été
bouleversée de l'intérieur et de
l'extérieur sans parvenir nécessairement
à retrouver un équilibre économique et
qui a d'ailleurs provoqué l'arrivée de
la dmr poutine au pouvoir et de la dmr
poutine une fois au pouvoir a cherché à
rétablir le prestige la sécurité et la
stabilité de la nouvelle russie
il y est en grande partie parvenu mais
il y est parvenu au prix d'une hostilité
maintenu avec je dirais le camp qu'on
appelait avant le camp de l'ouest et et
la réalité derrière tout ça c'est que ni
l'ouest ni la russie n'ont réussi à
gérer leurs relations
d'après la guerre froide c'est à dire
que des l'implosion ou l'explosion de
l'union soviétique
tous les anciens satellites soviétiques
d'europe centrale la pologne les pays
baltes se sont précipités vers l'otan
pour demander la protection de l'otan
pour ce sens que tu as risée et avoir la
garantie que plus jamais
troupes russes se lier tic ou pas mais
des troupes russes viendrait envahir
leur territoire et les primes et leur
liberté et l'otan à tort ou à raison et
je pense qu'ils avaient un intérêt à le
faire mains d'intérêts stratégiques à
long terme qui est beaucoup plus
discutable
l'otan s'est précipité dans la brèche
ouverte pour rendre service à ces pays
et venir étendre son périmètre jusqu'à
la limite de la russie qui a été une
manoeuvre interprété comme agressive de
la part de moscou qui a suscité cette
réaction hostile et aujourd'hui trente
ans plus tard on en est toujours au même
point qu'il ya en craignant fait partie
des points chauds qui sont je dirais la
conséquence de cette incertitude et de
ce manque de confiance je vois revenir à
rétablir d'une manière ou d'une autre la
confiance peut-être que les choses
annoncerait justement au niveau de la
confiance à ce sujet à dmitry très nine
le directeur du centre d'analysé
carnegie de moscou a dit il faut garder
à l'esprit que les deux parties ne se
font pas confiance mais ça veut dire
quoi quand vous parlez vous également de
la confiance ça veut dire que après ce
rendez vous entre joe biden et donald
trump
il y aura toujours un affrontement quoi
qu'il arrive puisqu'on a vu les deux
parties ont dix faut pas forcément
attendre grand chose de de ce rendez
vous notamment de mitry peskov
tout à l'heure le porte parole du
kremlin non il ne faut pas en attendre
grand chose à court terme mais moi je
vous parlais vraiment d'une raid d'une
relation à long terme ce que le thé en
confiance signifie ce signifierait que
de la part de la russie
on accepte l'idée que l'otan est une
alliance défensive et que son objectif
n'est pas d'encercler et d'asphyxier la
russie et de la part de l'otan la
confiance serait de reconnaître que la
russie est une nation indépendante qui
ne cherche pas à défendre son périmètre
si frau pierre actuelle nihad empêché ni
d'empêcher les pays hors de son
territoire de disposer de leur propre
souveraineté
c'est d'ailleurs ce que joe biden
cherche à défendre menadi qui n'allait
en ce qui concerne l'ukraine
défendre la souveraineté territoriale de
l'ukraine donc cherché à faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas d'intervention russe
ce titre là et la confiance et la
confiance elle est dans deux bleus
qui ont une histoire qui est issu de la
guerre froide et de ce point de vue là
joe biden a 78 ans c'est quelqu'un qui a
passé la moitié de sa carrière politique
sous la guerre froide et bladimir
poutine est un ancien officier du kgb
c'est quelqu'un qui a été éduqué dans un
contexte culturel et idéologique que ce
type la guerre froide et il semble
qu'aujourd'hui ces deux pays n'arrivent
pas à sortir de ce contexte
alors que le monde a considérablement
évolué voilà ce que ça signifie la
confiance est les premiers mots tout à
l'heure des deux hommes toujours mieux
de se rencontrer en tête à tête selon
joe biden et vladimir poutine qui je
cite espère une réunion productive
vladimir poutine a dit récemment à
espérer que byden soit moins impulsif
que donald trump pour un chef d'état est
ce qu'il faut mieux être impulsif ou
pondérer gérald olivier parce que ici on
va évoquer les lignes rouges qu'il ne
faut pas franchir comment est-ce que
vous analysez ces premiers mots de la
part des deux présidents ce qui est sûr
c'est que le président byden aura un
discours beaucoup plus scripté beaucoup
plus écrit il s'en tiendra un langage
diplomatique qui est celui que ses
conseillers lui incluant conseillé
d'adopter et c'est vrai qu'il aura une
approche totalement différente de celle
de donald trump
joe biden est quelqu'un qui a une très
très longue carrière de sénateur
derrière lui notamment en tant que
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat donc il sait ce que
c'est que les rencontres diplomatiques
il sait que le langage a des
conséquences et il évitera tout écart
donc de ce point de vue là il sera
beaucoup beaucoup plus prévisible plus à
la trup donald trump n'était pas un
homme politique professionnelle ce
n'était pas quelqu'un qui allait
nécessairement le sens de la diplomatie
et c'était quelqu'un qui faisait
confiance à son intuition et à son
instinct et qui donc par là étaient
parfois très impulsif
c'est qui a provoqué des écarts de
langage qui ont parfois plus pu être je
dirais mais interprétés mais le problème
que l'on rencontre et qui était évoquée
par vos reportages il ya quelques
secondes et
mon avis un problème propre à la
personne de joe biden c'est à dire que
joe brighton aux états unis doit lutter
contre l'image d'un président faible
on voit bien que du fait de son âge du
fait de sa santé
du fait d'une mémoire qui parfois lui
fait défaut il projette l'image d'un
président frêle et comme lui vaut au
contraire projeter une image de
puissance
eh bien il est amené à avoir des propos
qui déchoit excède je dirais le cadre
diplomatique pas forcément sa pensée
profonde
lorsqu'il dit que vladimir poutine est
un tueur
je crois que dans l'esprit de joe biden
il en est persuadé maintenant ils
avaient bien conscience que ce n'est pas
le langage qu'un président de fait avoir
par contre il estime que ça fait partie
de ce qui peut renforcer son image et
donc ils se livrent à ce genre des cas
je prends pour moi c'est totalement
inutile et contre productif parce que la
force comme dit le film star wars
elle est en vous et où elle n'y est pas
donald trump n'avait pas besoin de
propos forts pour projeter l'image d'un
président fort maiden au contraire en a
besoin et ce qui est encore plus
paradoxal c'est que sa politique
derrière n'est pas forcément une
politique de force
donc là il est assis entre deux chaises
dans une position qui est relativement
indélicate gâchant tous les cas ces
images on va pas les voir ce soir en
conférence de presse séparée
alors qu'en 2018 donald trump et
vladimir poutine s'était donc exprimés
ensemble pourquoi ce choix gérald
olivier de conférences de presse
séparées
écoutez officiellement l'explication qui
a été donnée par la maison blanche c'est
qu'il ne souhaitait pas offrir une plate
forme internationale à vladimir poutine
en le mettant sur le même plan que le
président américain
ça c'est là c'est la raison officielle
raison officieuse
on peut penser dans le camp démocrate et
notamment au sein de la maison blanche
que ils ont voulu éviter un exercice
dans lequel joe biden aurait pu
trébucher on voit bien que
l'improvisation c'est à dire affronter
les questions des journalistes si ces
questions ne lui ont pas été fournies à
l'avant ce n'est pas un exercice dans
lequel il est très à l'aise il m'a foule
souvent il fait des gaffes il se trompe
dans ses réponses et je pense que les
américains ont voulu jouer la sécurité
en évitant d'avoir une conférence de
presse où les deux dirigeants soient
l'un à côté de l'autre et éviter tout
annoncé et donc ils ont séparé les deux
éléments riposter contre un train
dialoguer ce sont les mots de recettes
borel le chef de la diplomatie
européenne
pourquoi ces sanctions contre la
biélorussie maintenant alors qu' à ce
sommet à genève et pourquoi employer ces
mots maintenant également gérald olivier
vous êtes chercheur à l'épaisseur
institut prospective sécurité en europe
vous avez l'union européenne se repose
sur la force du droit
à défaut d'être capable d'utiliser le
droit de la force
donc à partir de là ce sur quoi ils vont
mettre l'accent systématiquement ça va
être le respect d'un certain ordre
international
et cet ordre international nous dit que
lorsqu'un un vol d'une aviation civile
passe au dessus de votre territoire
eh bien vous n'envoyez pas votre avion
de chasse pour obliger cet avion à se
poser est kidnappé ou arrêtés l'un des
passagers de cet avion ce qui a été fait
en biélorussie et ce qui est une
violation on va dire des codes
internationaux à partir du moment où la
biélorussie est un pays qui existe et
qui est sous la protection on dirait un
direct mais quand même assez complice
ina de moscou on peut comprendre que
l'union européenne cherche à s'assurer
contre cet état de fait je me permets de
vous couper pascal alexandre loukachenko
le président de l'ukraine a évoqué une
alerte à la bombe un pur
dire pourquoi il a détourné ce volant
oui mais enfin ça c'est un prétexte
qu'elle personne ne fait confiance on
peut toujours ils vont toujours dire
quelque chose mais ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui peut
comment dirais-je être acceptée et
d'autre part s'il y avait une halle être
à la bourre pourquoi est ce qu'ils ont
fait descendre de passagers c'est pas
eux qui portaient la bombe avec eux
toujours est il que là vous aviez un
incident qui justifie une certaine
colère de la part de l'union européenne
mais ce que je voulais dire le vrai
problème de la diplomatie de l'union
européenne c'est que comme chacun sait
est la politique ou la guerre est la
continuation de la politique par
d'autres moyens et l'union européenne et
tente une union sans défense réelle sa
diplomatie n'a pas de poids et justement
les déclarations aujourd'hui les
sanctions aujourd'hui et ce timing alors
qu'à cette réunion entre vladimir
poutine et et joe biden est ce que ça
peut peser dans les négociations à la
ville à la grange de genève
non parce que je ne pense pas que joe
biden était informé de ce communiqué
c'est simplement un moyen pour l'union
européenne d'exister d'apparaître aux
informations du soir
le même jour que l'on a semé entre
poutine et brydon
mais les relations entre coutumes et
paris donnent se passe au dessus de
l'union européenne et même si il y à un
accord de principe dans je dirais la
gestion des affaires internationales
entre l'union européenne et les etats
unis
eh bien il n'y a pas je dirais de 2,2
d'accord keith utile que les états unis
vont suivre systématiquement la position
de l'union européenne
je crois que là monsieur josef proell a
essayé d'exister sur le plan médiatique
en mettant en avant une des classiques
principe qui est tout à son honneur
le problème c'est que l'union européenne
n'a absolument pas la force pour pouvoir
mettre en place des arguments et qu'à
partir de là ses propos mois ou un de
sens et de points gerald olivier on
vient d'évoquer notamment
le dossier ukrainien
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre sur
l'ukraine est ce qu'il peut y avoir des
avancées de part et d'autre alors il ya
deux choses à dire et deux choses très
importantes à mon avis la première c'est
qu'on ait fait l'ukraine c'est le
dossier le plus épineux
c'est le dossier le plus chaud parce que
l'ukraine c'est une poudrière
mais l'autre point à souligner qui
d'ailleurs a été évoquée par vos deux
reportages récents notamment le fait
qu'on a souligné qu' il ait des
entretiens et 3 a été terminée et cas
présent on avait des entretiens avec des
états-majors beaucoup plus étendue et
donc des entretiens petit peu plus
technique et on a l'impression que ce
sommet il a un petit peu inversée par
rapport au sommet de la diplomatie
habituel parce que habituellement les
diplomates négocié en coulisses en amont
du sommet et lorsqu'on a un sommet c'est
qu'on est parvenus à un accord et on
peut avoir les deux chefs d'état qui
viennent et qui part à cet accord devant
les caméras des journalistes et le
sommet via un petit peu conclure ainsi
que de négociations
et là c'est la situation inverse où on a
l'impression que le sommet cherche
plutôt à lancer un cycle de négociations
et qu'en fait la conclusion viendra
beaucoup plus tard alors je ne pense pas
qu'il dise ouverture concrète concernant
le sujet d'ukrainiens mais une
résolution ce que ce dossier serait
essentiel justement pour rétablir ce
dont on parlait beaucoup plus tôt qui
était d'établir cette fameuse confiance
c'est un sujet épineux parce que vous
avez craignent les conditions à la fois
avec une guerre civile
les conditions d'acompte ni régionales
et voir les conditions d'un conflit
puisse même s'étendre
donc c'est une situation extrêmement
périlleuse et qui serait je dirais très
important de parvenir à calmer et de
trouver une sorte de terrain d'entente
entre la russie ukraine otan et donc les
états unis comme un pays leader de le
temps où chacun trouve son compte
et cette situation pour moi il passe
d'un côté par une garantie de
l'interférence russe c'est à dire
interférences vis-à-vis de la
souveraineté
contactez territoriale de l'ukraine je
pense qu'on échange a que du côté
ukrainien et côté de l'otan on inclut ce
qui s'est passé avec la géorgie après
2008 c'est à dire l'idée que deux pays
seraient défendus mais qu'une produits
nature à l'otan n'étaient plus totale en
tout cas pas à court terme et à mon avis
cette résolution elle ne viendra
aujourd'hui mais elle fait partie des
termes d'une résolution structure qui
sera peut-être d'été aujourd'hui ce
sommet il lance donc du coup une période
de tractations selon vous mais il
conclut en tous les cas la tournée un de
joe biden en europe qui a commencé la
semaine dernière avec le sommet du g7 en
grande bretagne dans les cornouailles il
a continué à bruxelles avec le sommet de
l'otan et donc il conclut avec cette
rencontre avec vladimir poutine
et lors des précédents jours pendant le
g7 et une sortie du président ukrainien
volodimir zielinski qui a dit regretter
que joe biden rencontre vladimir poutine
avant lui
comment est-ce que vous analysez cette
sortie de volodymyr zemlinsky alors
d'une part le jeu s'est pas trop mal
passé pour bart hayden jusqu'à présent
d'autre part c'est vrai que
malheureusement joe biden est en
porte-à-faux son dossier et craignent
heures parce qu'il a déjà été impliqué
du temps où il était vice-président et
on sait qu'il a eu une influence directe
sur la politique ukrainienne puisque à
une époque il a obtenu le limogeage d'un
certain juge d'instruction qu'il estime
est cocu et en échange de ce jazz les
états unis aient donné leur accord pour
libérer une ligne de crédit à l'époque
de plus de 100 millions de dollars à
l'ukraine déjà été un fier
malheureusement son fils hunter a
également qui est dans le dossier
régnard a réussi à frites et
financièrement parlant de la position de
son du temps où il était dix qui propose
états unis donc de ce point de vue là la
position de dubaï
tactiquement je dirais non pas par salle
où elle est un petit peu inconfortable
parce qu'il a été à la fois juge et
partie et il était déjà impliqué
ailleurs le président ukrainien doit
bien se rendre compte que dans la
géopolitique et dans la stratégie des
états unis
l'ukraine est très peu par rapport à la
russie
donc le fait que respecter je dirais
l'ordre protocolaire en se rendant
d'abord vers le puissance des deux
rivaux ou des deux partenaires me paraît
être une évidence
maintenant encore une fois des états
unis l'otan l'union européenne vont
chercher à faire en sorte que les
relations avec la russie parviennent
qu'à évolué de sorte que le dossier
ukrainien quel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
ne puisse pas se reproduire je dirais à
l'avenir on en est loin de là mais c'est
l'objectivité on évoque le chiffre de
mille journalistes accrédités pour cette
réunion au sommet le fait qu'ils aient
autant de journalistes accrédités
gérald olivier ça vous évoque quoi c'est
quoi c'est comme la finale de la coupe
du monde de foot ans c'est vraiment très
très important oui oui ça fait partie du
théâtre médiatique internationale ça
fait de belles images
ça fait 2-2 longtemps d'antennes comme
vous le vivez actuellement comme
n'oubliez pas axer mon nom ça fait
partie du théâtre politique
internationale et c'est tout à fait
nécessaire c'est surtout tout à fait
nécessaire que les gens s'intéressent à
ce que ses deux dirigeants ont à dire
est ce que ces deux pays ont à faire
l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre parce que
après tout ce sont à l'arrivée c'est
nous les citoyens qui en bénéficieront
aux pieds en pâtiront est ce qu'il faut
espérer c'est qu'il n'y a pas simplement
un théâtre avec une jolie villa mais du
vide à l'intérieur et qu'il y aura de
véritables avancées
je pense que votre reporter évoqué le
fait que les deux ambassadeurs pourrait
réintégrer leurs sièges ce qui à mon
avis serait je dirais le minimum à
obtenir d'eux
de ce sommet parce que c'est vrai que
ils ont été rappelés chez eux du fait
d'un certain nombre d'accusations
restant notamment suite aux épisodes de
cybercriminalité dont les états unis on
compte été victime et au sujet desquels
ils ont accusé des hackers présent en
russie est sans doute ou peut-être
ouvert à tous toujours est il que
rétablir ce minimum de relations
diplomatiques
serai je dirais le succès minimum à
attendre datait de sommets et peut-être
d'autres choses plus tard mais encore
une fois n'ont su persuader il faudra
attendre de longs mois puisque ce que
l'on observe c'est que les négociations
sont en train de le débuter et on ne
sait pas du tout jusqu où ils vont aller
ni précisément son combat elle
comportait par contre il ya beaucoup de
sujets que ces deux pays ont à on a fait
le sujet de l'iran est essentielle le
sujet de la syrie est essentielle le
sujet à l'action commune entre la russie
union européenne et des etats-unis
vis-à-vis de la chine aurait abordé
je suis persuadé que monsieur pretend a
évoqué la question de la relève à la
transition énergétique
quelque chose qu'il a lancée aux états
unis lui a déjà réalisé par yves sur le
climat donc le sujet du climat est liée
à la transition énergétique a aussi
inévitablement ou bien a été mis sur la
table et c'est un sujet qui est
président content pour la russie puisque
l'afrique dépend d'une très large des
énergies fossiles entre économie une
série de sujets à être discuté et au
delà du petit théâtre politique
le contenu des discussions est
extrêmement important par rapport à 7
par rapport à cette rencontre et par
rapport à vous en tant que j'en ai ce
franco-américain vous allez souvent aux
états unis j'ai envie de dire quid de la
nouvelle génération politique puisqu'on
sait que joe biden
est issu de la vieille génération il a
78 ans il a vécu la guerre froide et
cette génération qui est souvent
hostiles à la russie mais qu'en est il
de la jeune pousse politique est-ce
qu'ils sont plus ouverts des relations
plus apaisée avec avec la russie c'est
une question très intéressante et une
question beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
complexe qu'il n'y paraît
parce qu'en effet la nouvelle génération
vous avez un certain nombre de
d'américains les millénium et la
génération z je ne sais plus comment les
appels mais il ya un certain nombre
d'américains qui sont nés après la
guerre froide qui n'ont jamais connu la
division du monde entre un mode libre
avec à sa tête les états unis et un
espace soviétique qui étaient conçus de
l'extérieur comme un espace carcéral et
quand on a vu aux états unis récemment
la montée de l'extrême gauche
la montée de bernie sanders la montée de
personnages politiques comme alexandria
occasion courtès qui est une jeune
représentant de new york qui est extrait
très à gauche mais bien sentiment que
ces gens ont pu avoir un impact sur
l'opinion parce que le socialiste il se
revendique d'être une réalité pour
génération et à partir de là cette
génération est beaucoup plus ouvert à
une vision plus social démocrate de la
société maintenant cette même génération
les imbiber de théologie des droits de
l'homme et habib et d'un certain
consumérisme axée sur des libertés
individuelles restent u11 de
l'environnement respectueuse de la
diversité et à partir de là les époques
rate et dirigeants autoritaires
c'est incroyable qu'il ya cet autre
son vis-à-vis de la russie un héritier
malgré tout dans ce pays c'est le pays
qui en est aujourd'hui
mais a donc à voir la saint patrick dans
le lit d'un second jour son dirigeant
fait partie des autocrates
il est là depuis l'an 2000 il a connu
quatre présidents américains différents
lui il est toujours en place son
ministre des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov est toujours en place depuis plus
de 20 ans et au pétrole
si peu que joe biden ne se produira
alors que poutine sera toujours dans à
partir de là nous rassure américaine se
méfie de ses hommes forts et il ya donc
une attitude quelque peu ambivalente
et de vladimir poutine merci gérald
olivier d'avoir répondu à toutes nos
questions c'était assez l'argent on a
évoqué un large panel je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste franco américain
chercheurs ali pse l'institut
prospective sécurité en europe et vous
êtes l'auteur de nombreux de nombreux
ouvrages sur les états unis notamment
sur la route de la maison blanche aux
éditions jean picollec il